[Music]
let's go to michelle in boston hey
michelle what's going on
hi john how are you good how are you
good um so my question today um
is how do i work with my husband to help
him battle
um his severe severe trauma from his
childhood um
and the ptsd and anxiety and depression
that he's left with today
even with one of his abusers still in
his life
um
and then also
how do we connect on a spiritual level
um
for his healing when some
a lot of his trauma came from people who
were
related to his church and
religious people
and that genre
um i feel like he holds back because of
it yeah of course we can't
and we can't really connect on that
level but even just so
even so he's just in such a bad place in
his life and
this person is still around and
[Music]
we just seem like stuck
yeah so is your husband going through
treatment of some sort is he is he on a
healing journey or is he just getting
through every day just grinding it out
he is on a healing journey but to be
completely honest he was forced to um
a couple years ago his body kind of
turned on him
and he
started what we thought were allergic
reactions turned into panic attacks
and his anxiety was taking over his body
um
so it it basically ate its way out and
now it's a it's a daily battle for him
um he could be completely honest before
me he used drugs and alcohol to of
course
yeah um why why is
why is an abuser still in his life
um
he has a
narcissistic mother okay she's uh did
she abuse him as a kid
physically abused as a kid he was also
sexually abused
by
other
others so did mom know about that
growing up not growing up um but she was
very physically abusive to him um after
her um after
she got divorced from their father
um
probably from like five
on
he was physically abused
very badly um but she's so narcissistic
uh and gaslighting that she
denies it um
so can i
he's a very in a very lonely place in
his head you know um so imagine this
imagine
there is a bear
that
eats
part of your arm and leg as a as a kid
as a child
just gnaws it off blood mass bones
breaking all of it
and then
that bear
just lives in your living room
forever
right
your body would never
heal and you'll just die young
right and until he decides to he's got
to
create
significant
strong
disconnected boundaries from his mom
so that he until he gets that bear out
of his living room
and creates somewhat of a safe place
where his heart can stop racing and his
head can stop going hey she's right
there she's right there
right
he's not he did it
we did move um so we did move away from
where we're a couple hours away yeah and
that can make it worse that can make it
worse
because then the communication is
electronic
and that gaslighting
and she's the worst exactly
and so he needs to take his phone out
and block her
today more comments for birthday too so
well happy birthday
right he just he just uh wrote to me a
little while ago saying he did call her
and
he
i feel like he's my
child because i'm like i'm trying to
hold up the boundaries he hey he is he
you've he's become your kid
and your mom
and that's not a way to hold on to a
marriage and my guess is you're getting
exhausted
and you love him like crazy and you're
getting exhausted
because i'm also i'm scared for my kids
yeah of course they really they really
love their grandmother and um
but i mean it's all part of the game you
know grandmother realize that her love
isn't real a bear
yeah
that tried to kill your
husband she does not get access to your
kids for a long time
and listen
my kids love people that give them candy
i'm still discriminating against about
who they're involved with
right
and you've got this picture and it's an
incredible one of your mother-in-law
coming around and being this awesome
grandma
and we all go play that is over
it's it's really creepy
it's scary and it's over
and you have to draw that boundary and
your husband's got to draw that boundary
and when it comes to spiritual
connection
it wasn't a bear
it was a
firing squad
it was a torture chamber for your
husband
and so any sort of faith healing
is going to have to be unbraided from
the people that hurt him
and so
trying to connect with him in the
torture chamber
is gonna be a challenge for a season
[Music]
does that make sense
yeah
and you're going to feel lonely because
you want to connect with him on a
spiritual level and you want to raise
your kids in a certain way and he's
going to continue to remember
that's where i was sexually abused
that's not safe yeah we can't
he can't even go back to his
we where we grew up he can't even go
back of course of course it's been
slowly happening for a long time and
um
he's
he he just
i'm realizing like i do a lot of
research and i try to find things and i
just sent him a thing about triggers
with his ptsd because
he goes we don't even know what sets him
off
some days um but i know it could be
literally anything it could be a song it
could be a
um
a way someone something said a smell of
this or that so
you know he goes into these
breakdowns and has a full-on panic
attack
and um
you know i all i'm i'm just trying to
get him out you know help him out and
help him
through it and so he here's the thing
here's the thing
number one i'm so sorry michelle
this is so hard
it's so hard
and you are a strong strong woman he's
lucky to have you in his life
and you're also
his mom now too
and you are trying to solve this and you
can't solve it you can't fix him
i'm telling you right now 1 000
chance not a doubt in my mind
if he wants to heal from this trauma
he can
no question about it
it will be a gauntlet he will walk
through hell and back and he will need
somebody strong like you by his side
but he's got to do the walk on his own
you can't lay in this bed with him you
can hold his hand while he's in it but
you can't do it for him
and if he wants to get to the bottom of
vanderkolt says trauma is not what
happened
it is our body's response in the present
to things that happened in the past
right so until he decides i want to
regain control of my body in the present
i cannot heal the fact that my mom the
one woman on on the planet
who was supposed to take care of me
abuse the crap out of me
i can't fix i can't change that
i can't change the fact that the one
safe place i should be able to go to is
with my faith community
took my innocence away they stole that
from me
they sexually abused me
you can't change that what i can change
is how my body and the president
responds to things that happen in the
past
and that's what healing trauma is
but he's got to decide that
right and you can't make it it's so hard
with the mother mother i know that's why
she's got you got to get the bear out of
the living room first
the body's never going to heal it can't
she keeps biting him scratching him
right and then at the same time your kid
hurt your kids are on that beer's back
having the time of their life just
playing playing playing
right you got to get that bear out of
the living room she has cashed in
she's out
she doesn't get to be mom for a season
right
and then she and then she turns that
around on us
it doesn't matter she is an abuser
i don't care what she says she gets no
votes
she gets no votes in my house i don't
care what she turns around okay what she
says she is does not exist
does that make sense
yeah
it's say it say it she doesn't get a
vote in my house anymore
you're right she doesn't get a vote in
my house anymore say it with conviction
you're a powerful
right would you would you let some
stranger some strange man just come live
in your living room
and your husband walks in and he would
just punch your husband in the face and
they'd hand your kids some candy would
you allow that
right now no you wouldn't you'd go to
war for your husband you'd go to war for
those kids
and just because it's it's his mom
doesn't make it it makes it more evil
not less it makes it more painful more
hurtful
and your husband feels trapped and the
moment he unplugs from mom will be the
first day he starts to get well
okay
because his body is continuing to fight
and fight and flee
and run and freeze
from a threat that he's been under for
30 something years
right
and it's time to get the bear out of the
living room
and you can heal from a faith community
for sure
but he's gonna have to walk through hell
to get there
it's gonna be hard and it may look
different than you and your fantasy and
you're in in the world you the picture
you have
it may look different ultimately
right
right because they still there's um
yeah my best friend is his sister and
his so
um and in the past
the sisters have been used as weapons by
the mom so i don't ever want to hear
about your mother-in-law ever again
right
i know i know yeah okay and tell the
sister tell your best friend
mom's not welcome here anymore oh my
gosh are you serious yes not welcome
she's an abuser
i for sure i'm not letting my little
kids around her
and
i am going to do everything i can to
keep my husband out of that woman's
presence so that
his body can finally recognize that he's
safe
and i'm gonna go back
to being his lover
his partner in life his best friend i'm
gonna stop being his mom
i'm gonna quit being his mother
and i'm gonna create a well home a safe
home
with him he's gonna play a part in this
and he's gonna decide
i'm worth being well and i'm worth being
completely plugged in and connected with
my kids i'm worth being completely
plugged in and having a reckless wild
love with my wife
and he's gonna have to learn how to do
that
because the first woman didn't love him
she abused him the faith community
didn't love him it abused him
his sisters are a mess
and it's going to be tempting for you to
keep punishing mom to keep going back to
mom i don't care about her she doesn't
get a vote
she's done
and this is hard
i'd love love love for you to give us a
shout back and i'd love to talk to your
husband
both of y'all on the phone at the same
time that'd be awesome i'd love to just
listen to his story and walk alongside
him
but remember these three things
you cannot fix him you can love him you
can stay physically connected to him you
can hold him you can look him in the eye
and say i love you
but you can't fix him
he has to decide i want to be well
and by the way he's not broken
he needs healing
he's hurt he's not broken
the second thing is get mother-in-law
out she gets no more votes done get the
bear out of the house
number three i want you and your husband
you've got to you michelle
you got to put this fantasy picture down
of what you've created of this perfect
life it's different now
it's different
i want you and him to go co-create what
this thing's gonna look like you're
gonna do it season by season by season
what's the next six months gonna look
like for us is it summer is it winter is
it spring or or or fall what's it going
to look like
we're going to slowly rebuild this thing
and we're going to paint a picture
together
and it sounds all cheesy it's
not you all have to excavate everything
and rebuild something totally new
that doesn't include mother-in-law
ah michelle he's so lucky to have you
he's so lucky to have you
thank you so so much for your call